Welcome to now you see it
brought forth in art form,
centered around seeing motion on the
screen,
but film is far more than only visual
music plays a huge role in that
heightened realism of what the fuck that
means.
Different film scores can completely
alter the mood of a scene and filmmakers
carefully pick their soundtracks or film
scores to convey certain emotions or
ideas.
I want to look at the psychology of
music,
how our brains respond to different
auditory stimulation in movies
to talk about music in a film,
I should distinguish between a
soundtrack and a score.
A film score is written specifically for
what's happening on a screen while the
soundtrack contained songs independent
from the movie itself that weren't made
only for the movie.
Most films have both and one example is
forest gump,
which has a soundtrack of songs not
solely associated with the movie
and a film score with music written
specifically and only for that
to really understand the importance of
the music in a film,
you should compare final cuts of movies
with the intended film score and cuts
with removed or edited music.
The famous psycho shower scene is so
much less frightening without a score.
My favorite example to show the
importance of music in a film is the
altering of this scene in the pirates of
the Caribbean,
depending on the music,
the seem to become triumphant,
creepy or comical.
Using music to psychologically altruist
scene has been around the silent era.
Silent movies used to be accompanied
with a live piano player who would play
along with the movie.
At first,
the music didn't interact with the movie
at all and was only there to avoid
silence in the theater,
but later piano players would either
improvise a lot with the movie or
receive sheet music to play.
Along with the psychology of the
accompaniment was pretty
straightforward.
When the screen shows a villain,
the piano player plays a diminished
minor chord,
which sounds Erie and unnerving.
Heroes get uplifting anthems.
Chase scenes have a fast tempo
and sad scenes are slow and
early.
Psychological musical techniques set the
standard for film scores in modern
cinema,
and while the orchestras have gotten
bigger and the score is more effective,
the general ideas of silent film,
piano,
a company might have remained the same.
The shower scene in psycho is a perfect
example of the psychology of music in
film.
In the scene,
Mary Crane gets stabbed to death in the
shower,
and the scene features one of the most
effective film scores in history.
This screeching sound of the violin
mimic sounds we biologically associate
with stress and danger.
The sound mimics cry for help.
A study by the University of California
in 2010 found that nonlinear alarm
sounds give us an emotional response
that instinctively unsettles us
psychologically,
Bernard Herman,
that composer of psycho purposefully
constructed the film score to mimic
these unsettling noises and the effect
makes the scene significantly scarier
and more unsettling.
Right?
In Jaws,
we hear the music before we see any
danger.
This technique unsettles us in a
different way.
The anticipation of the danger is what
makes each scene so scary.
The fact that we know something bad is
about to happen and the characters in
the movie don't know,
add suspense to the scene.
We are warned of the danger through the
film score and have no choice but to
watch the horror unfold as the music
slowly speeds up,
so does the camera and we feel
psychological terror from the disorder
of the music and the anticipation of the
inevitable.
The majority of film scores,
though purposefully stay in the
background and only provide subtle cues
to the audience.
Film score pioneer Aaron Copland gave
five ways a score serves the screen and
most of them stay in the background.
The first is to create a more convincing
atmosphere of time.
Place.
This one is pretty self explanatory.
Many genres and settings have their own
style of music to go with.
The style of the film score puts us into
a particular setting or genre.
A classic example would be the Western,
which has a very distinct sound,
so when bill and Ted go back in time to
the west,
the music changes along with them.
How's it going on Western?
Just like friends
cheerla.
Yeah.
Second music can underline psychological
refinements,
unspoken thoughts or unseen,
dangerous get shown or reinforced
through the music.
We may not see the danger,
but the music reminds us.
It's their traced.
The call is coming from inside though
to cut and edit any muggins you just.
That's weird.
Yesterday I went food shopping for like
15 minutes.
I used a computer before I went to the
store and when I came back,
my history,
it was gone.
The cash was cleared and the cookies had
been reset.
Third is to build a sense of continuity.
It's the music between shots or scenes
is the same.
We relate those scenes to each other.
This includes montages or flashbacks.
Excellent
citizen king uses musical cues as an
indicator of a flashback.
He was with Mr Kane and me the first day
Mr Kane took over the choir
in.
Catch me if you can.
The music is acute that the chase is on.
Fourth is to give a sense of finality,
copland's notes that this takes place
usually at the end of the film or after
some major trial.
The triumph that sound of the music
psychologically links us to the triumph
on screen,
and finally Coplin says,
sometimes music is just there to fill
the silence.
Interestingly,
he states that this is the hardest films
court to do because the audience
shouldn't notice it.
Holiday that recognizes that May 21st
other mother's Day.
Thank you.
Thanks.
In a clockwork orange,
Kubrick has uplifting orchestra music
play while extreme acts of violence
occur on screen,
the contradiction between comfort and
classical music and destruction that
adds tension and to
scores enhance the emotion of a scene,
but sometimes directors choose to not
use any music in this can work just as
well.
In no country for old men,
the vast majority of the movie has no
music but mostly dialogue in ambient
noise and it totally works.
Hearing nothing but a man's struggle for
his life is pretty menacing.
The storming of the beach scene and
saving private Ryan overwhelms the
senses with the sounds of gunshots.
Explosions and cries for help
instead of a film score.
Our brains often subconsciously react
differently to a visual given the music
playing behind it.
I think it's really interesting because
of how subtle film scores can be and yet
how vital they are to a movie.
The psychology of music is one of the
most important cinematic techniques and
fill the emotional infomatic potential
of these techniques is limitless,
and I've only scratched the surface.
So take your favorite film,
watch it again,
and pay close attention to the music and
how it enhanced the film.
Maybe without you even noticing.
How does that sound?
Thanks for watching.
I love the books that I recommended,
even if he didn't.
Glen funding
dream.